when night falls in Southeast Nigeria
light is a scarce resource many homes
here are connected to the public grid
but electricity is expensive and power
outages are common that's often meant
turning to diesel generators as a backup
solution electrical engineer a man will
obey ugh Boehner came up with another
idea
he built a multifunctional device
charged by solar panels it's a clock a
lamp and a mobile phone charger all in
one when there's a power outage it uses
solar energy stored in a battery most
time we do so far power outage and as a
result of that most people find it
difficult to charge their phones and as
well to you know use lights at night so
the essence of this solar rechargeable
emergency work lot lighting system is to
provide lights in a house where there's
public power outage it takes a manual
about 3 hours to make a single clock the
clock then costs the equivalent of about
80 euros so it's not cheap but Emmanuel
has still been able to sell 16 of them
Taylor model chechik wall was one of his
first customers
since I bought it it'll be helping me
especially the gym booster in four hours
emergency light it was all of them even
the ion ion booster and porch lights as
his daddy has been working the manual
hopes his invention will soon be
mass-produced that way the clock would
be much more affordable what it is mass
produce depends we fought down to ten
thousand air yell Assad because here the
clock will be mass produce the materials
will be mass produce there were coupled
MBA we apply huge dr. have no job we
don't give that job Emmanuel has big
plans for the future he dreams of
expanding his business and exporting is
environmentally friendly invention to
other African countries